we have these photos that were taken and
I actually asked Will Arnett about this
but it's you oh look at lil Arnett there
he is walking in New York City and the
paparazzi caught you two holding hands
now will will maintains that he told me
that you guys saw the paparazzi and
staged this is that that's correct I
suppose well looking for real estate
yeah what were you look were you looking
for a play a place we're looking for a
apartment we work you work we were we
were talked about a little bit wills a
bit of a homophobe he's he's he's he's
not yet confident to go ahead and kick
the door down I tell him closets are for
clothes and he tells me no I'm gonna
stay in it but we're were were sweet on
each other I think is what I saw a loft
that would probably fit fit me and the
kids and him and his kids and he says we
were doing paparazzi but but in fact we
were on a little bit of a real estate
hunt there you you guys are gonna get a
place together you're going to get I
think I think will arnett is one of the
best human beings on the planet I think
he fills out a white v-neck like no
one's business
because look good yeah we've got
shoulders like a hanger yeah you know
and you know the times were sweet when
you know I could I could start my day
with him and end my day with him on
Arrested Development you know I get to
work while the Sun was still down and I
get home after the sun's down I mean I'm
with him all day I don't even see my you
know the beard you know I leave before
the beard get it right the beard I'm out
stalker Conan I'm out here I'm lightning
with the handsome audience so so more
Arrested Development would be great
Jesus so that I can be back with my
beloved okay I'm glad you got that off
your chest
yeah that's really nice quick great
watching honey remembers the same
you